CANADA LIFE CENTRE BEFORE THIS
MONTH WILL COME TO AN
TRAVIS TOONY AND KENDRICIT, H
BOUNCING PUCK AND NATHAN
MacKINNON WILL GET IT TO THE
FRONT
TO THE NEAR POST, J.T. COMPHER
BY AUBE-KUBEL AND THIS MAY HAVE
GONE OFF A JET AND IN.ATTEMPT A
DILLON IS RIGHT WHEREZONE.
GETS A LITTLE PASS INTO THE FEET
BUT BATTERS THAT TO THE STICK
AND MAKES THE PLAY, UP TNER BOA
SANFORD HOLDING THE BEFOROCENT ,
A CONTROLLED FORECHECK,L CARRY .
HE'LL DROP IT BACK, SHOT SCORES.
NOW YOUR GAP IS OFF.
YOU'RE BACK UP AND YOUOU FRONT T
NATHAN MacKINNON IN TO THE
CORNER BOARDS BY LOWRY.X OUT NE.
YOU WIN THE BATTLE OUT O
J.T. COMPHER, BUT HE TURNS IT
OVER TOIT, TAKING TO
THE BACK BOARDS IS DEVON TOEWS,
.
LOOK HOW LOW IN THE DEFENSIVE
ZONE HE GETS THE P PUCKS GRABBE.
MORRISSEY THE BLOCK, LOOSE PUCK,
SCORES!NUES ON, CRISP
MOVEMENT, SHOT TO THE NET, TIP
AND REBOUND AALIVE, HANGING BY
TONIGHT, LLON, CROSS
ICE, SCORES!